It used to be back in the day that when a hardware manufacturer, like the day that they announced a new chip, the day that we said, hey, here's this chip with this name, you know, when the day in 2017 when Volta announced, when Jensen announced Volta, he had the chip available to hold it up. And like, you know, that was exciting. It was like you didn't know about this thing before the conference. And like now it's like, you know, we show our roadmap there and it's like we show the road we announce the next chip like a year before it's going to be out and then we say
过去，当硬件制造商宣布一款新芯片时，比如他们宣布芯片名称的那一天，你知道，2017年Jensen宣布Volta架构的那天，他手里拿着芯片展示给大家看。那真的很令人兴奋。在会议之前你根本不知道会有这个东西。而现在，我们会在会上展示路线图，在芯片发布前一年就宣布下一款芯片，然后我们还会说
something about the next next chip and then we even like say what the name of the next next next chip is going to be be which is Feynman. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 226 recorded on March 20th 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about Bryce's experience at both the NVIDIA GTC 2017 conference and his recent experience at the NVIDIA GTC 2025 conference. How's it been buddy? You are live.
关于下下款芯片的一些信息，甚至还会说出下下下款芯片的名字，也就是Feynman。欢迎收听ADSP播客第226期，录制于2025年3月20日。我是Connor，今天我和联合主持人Bryce一起，聊聊他在2017年英伟达GTC大会上的经历，以及他最近参加2025年英伟达GTC大会的感受。伙计，感觉怎么样？你现在正在直播。
Oh God, Connor, Connor, my butt, my soul has left my body. It is day four of the GPU technology conference and I am an old man. I do not know if I will survive. This is just because it's from morning Tonight's nonstop stuff and you're... It's from Morning Tonight nonstop stuff and me, Jake Hempstead and some of our other co-workers were at a nice team dinner last night but we got home pretty late. And I have had to. Oh, they scheduled my talk at 8 AM yesterday morning, which meant I had to be there at like 6 AM. Oh, man.
天哪，Connor，Connor，别提了，我的灵魂都出窍了。今天是GPU技术大会的第四天，我已经是个老头子了。我不知道自己能不能撑过去。因为从早到晚都是马不停蹄的活动，我和Jake Hempstead还有其他同事昨晚去吃了一顿不错的团队晚餐，但回家很晚。而且我不得不……哦，他们把我的演讲安排在昨天早上8点，这意味着我6点就得赶到现场。天哪。
This is a crazy, crazy conference. This is like, there's like 25,000 people here for GTC, which is Nvidia's tech conference where we talk about AI things. There's this crazy exhibition floor, and it just takes over San Jose. it's too large for the convention center. So it's spread across the convention center in three or four other locations. And it's a madhouse. It's a ton of fun.
这是一场疯狂的会议。GTC是英伟达的技术大会，我们在这里讨论人工智能，现场大约有25000人。这里有一个疯狂的展览大厅，它几乎占领了整个圣何塞。会议中心已经容纳不下了，所以它分散在会议中心和其他三四个地点。这里简直是个疯人院，但非常有意思。
Oh, they have a candy wall, which is a giant wall with, you know those things that they have coffee beans in that you can like open up and then the coffee beans spill out into your bag? What? Oh, like in a grocery store? Yes, like yes, where you'd get like nuts or coffee beans or something. Like in the bulk aisle kind of thing.
哦，他们有一个糖果墙，就是一个巨大的墙，你知道那种装咖啡豆的容器吗？你可以打开它，让咖啡豆倒进袋子里？什么？哦，就像杂货店里那样？是的，就像你在那里买坚果、咖啡豆之类的东西。就像散装食品区那种。
Tube, yeah. So they had one of those for candy. Yes, where you'd get like nuts or coffee beans or something like in the bulk aisle kind of thing tube Yeah So they had one of those for candy and I Was doing so good with my diet buddy, but the candy Yes, it is Free stuff in general. I don't know if a candy wall would do it for me a donut wall They had a donut wall at the end of a 10k race I ran once and then I took a bite like right after finishing and almost was sick.
管子，对。他们给糖果也用了那种装置。是的，就像你在散装食品区买坚果或咖啡豆的那种管子。所以他们给糖果也用了那种装置，我本来减肥减得很好，但那些糖果……是的，总的来说都是免费的东西。我不知道糖果墙对我有没有吸引力，甜甜圈墙倒是有。我曾经参加过一次10公里长跑，终点有个甜甜圈墙，我跑完后咬了一口，差点吐出来。
See I can't recommend that. Oh yeah by the way, this is the weekly or monthly fire alarm test that of course they're going to record while we're doing this so you continue telling your story while I mute my mic. No, no, no, it's interactive. My mother said she listened to episode two to one of our of your podcast. And she says, please make sure to tell Connor that the inception slash Juno actress he mentioned is now a dude. Elliott Page, the Alleyne Page. Elliot Page, ne Eileen Page.
看，我可不推荐那样做。哦，对了，顺便说一下，这是每周或每月的火警测试，当然他们会在我们录音时进行，所以你继续讲你的故事，我先把麦克风静音。不，不，不，这是互动的。我妈妈说她听了我们播客的第221期。她说，请一定要告诉Connor，他提到的那个《盗梦空间》或《朱诺》里的女演员现在是个男的了。Elliot Page，Alleyne Page。Elliot Page，原名Eileen Page。
I mean, I was actually, one, I knew this, but two, I was actually pretty careful, I think, not to misgender Elliot because I was referring to the character that they played who was a she. I mean, in the Juno movie if yes memory calls correctly that was before they had transitioned to Elliot so I was aware and I was also like cognizant when I was making the point and then when I couldn't come up I couldn't actually remember I can't remember if I was trying to remember
其实，第一，我知道这件事；第二，我觉得我当时很小心，没有用错Elliot的代词，因为我指的是他扮演的那个角色，那个角色是女性。我的意思是，如果记忆没出错的话，在《朱诺》那部电影里，那是在他变性为Elliot之前，所以我知道这一点，而且我在表达观点时也很有意识。我当时想不起来，我不记得我是在努力回忆……
Elliot or the name of the individual but I think I don't know someone can go I'm not gonna go back and check but I think while editing it I was I was careful to make sure that I didn't say the wrong thing Right. Oh, yeah, that's right. Okay. Why don't why am I saying? Um, it's Juno The reason I brought her up was because it was specifically from inception right that the dream folding its self over Or like the the world folding itself over which is it's less important the actress or actor I guess now but more was it important that the character in the movie is capable of folding worlds over on itself but thank you for the feedback I don't know why my mom is now listening to the podcast I
Elliot还是那个人的名字，但我认为，我不知道，有人可以去查，我不会回去核实，但我认为在剪辑时，我很小心地确保自己没有说错话。对。哦，对了，没错。好吧。为什么我要说……嗯，是《朱诺》。我提到她是因为那是专门讲《盗梦空间》的，对吧？那个梦境折叠自身，或者说世界折叠自身，这其实不重要，那个演员现在是男是女，重要的是电影里的角色有能力让世界折叠。但谢谢你的反馈。我不知道为什么我妈妈现在开始听这个播客了，我……
think maybe she's she's stalking me or something um yeah I mean I those two back-to-back episodes, I mean, especially the one after that, there was a lot of, what do I call it, inserts of other media, clips from whatever, movies and whatnot. But yes, thank you, Bryce's mom, for the feedback. Also the lovely note on one of the postcards you sent me.
我想也许她在跟踪我什么的。嗯，是的，那两期连续的节目，尤其是后面那一期，有很多，我该怎么说呢，插入了其他媒体的内容，来自电影之类的片段。但是的，谢谢Bryce的妈妈提供的反馈。还有你寄给我的明信片上写的可爱留言。
She had written something, I believe. Oh, that's right, that's right. It's funny because like, postcards have such an unpredictable latency. We sent, we like collect postcards now and so we send a lot of postcards and the worst ones was we sent some postcards from Japan that took like between six to 12 months to get like fully delivered. Damn. And like they also have like a pretty a pretty substantial droplet rate. Yeah. Like I only think like 80 percent of them get through because I know we sent you other postcards
她写了一些东西，我想。哦，对了，对了。很有趣，因为明信片有种不可预测的延迟。我们现在喜欢收集明信片，所以我们寄了很多，最糟糕的一次是我们从日本寄出的明信片，花了6到12个月才完全送达。该死。而且它们的丢失率也相当高。是的。我觉得只有80%能寄到，因为我知道我们还给你寄过其他明信片，
and I think at least one set of the postcards did not arrive. and I think at least one set of the postcards did not arrive. And I think part of it is like, and look, no offense to Canada, okay? But like, we're in the world, like you know, we're in Morocco and we ask someone like, you know, okay, like we want to send a postcard to, you know, to Canada or to the US or somewhere. And we just have to trust that they know what they're talking about. And I think that maybe there's been a couple times where we've tried to send a postcard to Canada
我觉得至少有一套明信片没收到。我觉得部分原因是，听着，对加拿大没有冒犯的意思，好吗？但我们在世界各地，比如我们在摩洛哥，我们问别人，我们要寄一张明信片到加拿大或美国或其他地方。我们只能相信他们知道自己在做什么。我想可能有几次我们试图寄明信片到加拿大时，
where they've been like, hmm, maybe Canada's in Europe or something. And then they've given us the wrong postage for sending something to Canada. I mean, the topic of Canada may or may not come up later when we talk about Twitter, Tesla, and Elon, because we have to revisit a topic. I'm not sure if you recall what we talked about,
他们会想，嗯，也许加拿大在欧洲什么的。然后他们给了我们错误的邮资。我的意思是，关于加拿大这个话题，稍后当我们谈论Twitter、特斯拉和Elon时可能会提到，因为我们必须重温一个话题。我不确定你是否还记得我们谈论过什么，
but we're gonna shelf that for maybe part two of this, because we should get back. I mean, and also part of the problem is I moved in between. So I think you sent it, and if they had shown up on time, I think we would have gotten those postcards, but I think just the the delay I suppose that's that's that's a possible. Do you have so in the US? There's like this service where you can like do mail forwarding which um Which is great because I I still haven't updated my address from when we moved last year, so
但我们先把这个搁置到第二部分吧，因为我们应该回到正题。而且部分问题是我搬家了。所以我想你寄出了，如果它们准时到达，我想我们应该能收到那些明信片，但我认为只是延迟……我想这是一种可能。在美国，有一种服务叫邮件转发，这很棒，因为我去年搬家后还没更新地址，所以……
We still get a lot of mail at our old address and they just route it to us. Who does that? Is it the mail postal service? Yeah. That is something that Canada may or may not have. I have never looked into that. I just assume that like if it's...
我们仍然在旧地址收到很多邮件，他们只是把邮件转寄给我们。谁提供这种服务？是邮政服务吗？是的。加拿大可能也有也可能没有。我从来没查过。我只是假设如果它是……
Is the Canadian postal service called the Royal something something? No, it's called Canada Post. All right. Anyways, back. We so we should stay on the topic of GTC because one I've never been and I don't think you did. You've never been to JGC. I remember we've told this story a couple of times that I was going to go the very first year.
加拿大邮政服务叫皇家什么什么吗？不，它叫加拿大邮政。好吧。总之，回到正题。我们应该继续讨论GTC，因为第一，我从来没去过，而且我不认为你……你从来没去过GTC。我记得我们讲过几次这个故事，我本来打算第一年就去的。
I joined and I joined in October of 2019, which was for those keeping track, like five months before the pandemic went full swing, GTC got canceled. The next year it was online. I think maybe it was two years in a row it was online. And then it's been two years in person. And just both of these years I haven't been presenting a talk. I actually I had been to GTC in 2017, I had been to GTC in 2017, like four months before I joined Nvidia, but I have not been to in-person GTC since then. Although somebody may be pointing out that may not have been true. I may have been to one other one, but I don't, I really don't think so. I don't think I've been to in-person GTC since 2017, since I joined. Well, you know, we should have had you give,
我是在2019年10月加入的，对于那些记得的人来说，那是在疫情全面爆发前五个月，GTC被取消了。第二年是在线举办的。我想可能连续两年都是在线的。然后这两年是线下举办的。这两年我都没有做演讲。其实我在2017年参加过GTC，在我加入英伟达前四个月，但我从那以后就没参加过线下的GTC了。虽然有人可能会指出那可能不是真的。我可能还参加过一次，但我真的不觉得。自从我加入后，我不认为我参加过线下的GTC。好吧，你知道，我们本应该让你做演讲的，
we gave all these talks about like, Intro to Cuda C++, like how to write GPU code in idiomatic C++, and we should have just had you give the talk that I was gonna give, because I killed myself over the past two weeks, you know, trying to get all my slides ready on top of all the other, all the other GTC related things. So before, before we get to your talk, because it is,
我们做了所有关于Cuda C++入门的演讲，比如如何用地道的C++编写GPU代码，我们本应该让你做我那个演讲的，因为过去两周我为了准备幻灯片，还要处理所有其他与GTC相关的事情，简直累死了。所以在我们谈到你的演讲之前，因为现在是……
it is March 20th very early in the morning for Bryce 7 AM it's, it's 10 AM local time. Cause I'm still on the East coast. I watched the keynote on Tuesday and I've seen two and a half talks since then. I watched your talk, I believe at like 2 a.m. last night and I've lost many hours of sleep due to having watched your talk because I just I just have I have so many follow up questions. But before we get to my comments and my questions, because there was a couple questions live, and now we'll link it in the show notes, folks.
3月20日，对Bryce来说是清晨7点，当地时间是上午10点。因为我还在东海岸。我周二看了主题演讲，从那以后看了两个半演讲。我昨晚大约凌晨2点看了你的演讲，因为看了你的演讲我少睡了很多小时，因为我实在有太多后续问题了。但在我们谈到我的评论和问题之前，因为现场有几个问题，我们会在节目说明中附上链接，各位。
It is available via replay on the GTC website. Unfortunately, you do have to log in via email. We are working on getting them just posted on YouTube. But by the time I'm done my career at NVIDIA, we will just be posting stuff to YouTube like every other technology company. Nvidia, we're still getting there. The market cap's there, but we're still working on
它可以通过GTC网站的回放观看。遗憾的是，你必须通过电子邮件登录。我们正在努力把它发布到YouTube上。但在我结束在英伟达的职业生涯之前，我们应该会像其他科技公司一样把内容发布到YouTube上。英伟达，我们还在努力。市值是到了，但我们还在处理……
some, the edges of some stuff. But before we get to your talk, or we can skip straight to it, what are your, having been, at least according to your memory, this is the first time you've been to GTC in person, it's obviously much different. What is it like?
一些边缘问题。但在我们谈到你的演讲之前，或者我们可以直接跳到那部分，作为（据你记忆）第一次亲自参加GTC的人，这显然非常不同。感觉怎么样？
Were you at the keynote in person where there's like a stadium full of people? Like what are the highlights? So I tried to be at the keynote in person. I really did try, but you know what happened, Connor, is a very brice thing, which is I did not read any of the prep material. I read the one email that said don't try to like drive to,
你亲自参加了主题演讲吗？那里有坐满人的体育场吗？亮点是什么？我确实尝试亲自参加主题演讲。我真的试过了，但你知道发生了什么吗，Connor，这是一件非常“Bryce”的事情，那就是我没有读任何准备材料。我读了那封邮件，上面说不要试图开车去会议中心停车，因为没有停车位。所以，作为一个理智的人，主题演讲是10点开始，我8点半离开酒店，8点45分或8点50分到达总部，
in park at the convention center because there's gonna be no parking. And so I, and that there will be a shuttle from Nvidia's headquarters to the convention center. So I, you know, reasonable person, got up at, keynote was at 10, I left the hotel at 830, got to headquarters at like 845, 850,
我停在我以前工作的楼里，也就是新大楼，Voyager或Endeavor，两个中的一个，我们都以航天飞机命名。重点是那两栋楼隔着一条三车道的高速公路，我去问前台，嘿，去GTC的班车在哪里？她说，哦，在S楼。S楼离我在英伟达园区停车的地方尽可能远。
and I parked in the building that I used to work in, which is, you know, the new building, Voyager or Endeavor, one of the two, we named them both for space shuttles. The point is those two buildings are across a three-lane highway and I go and ask the receptionist, hey where's the shuttle to GTC? She's like, oh it's in building S. Building S is as far away from where I parked on the Nvidia campus as possible.
所以我心想，啊，太棒了。现在我得走20分钟去坐班车。我走到班车点，现在大约是9点15分。我等班车。班车9点30分出发。我想，好吧，太好了。我有足够的时间。
And so I'm like, ah, great. Now I got to walk 20 minutes to get to the shuttle. I walk over to the shuttle. It's now like 9.15. And I wait for the shuttle. The shuttle leaves at 9.30. I'm like, all right, great. I got plenty of time.
我到了会议中心。我问会议中心的人，嘿，主题演讲在哪里？他们说，哦，主题演讲在SAP中心，那个体育馆，他们举办音乐会的地方。那要走20分钟。所以我心想，好吧，太棒了。所以我不得不打个Uber过去。
I get to the convention center. I ask someone at the convention center, hey, where's the keynote? And they're like, oh, the keynote's over at the SAP center at the sports stadium, where they do concert events. And that's a 20 minute walk away. So I'm like, all right, wonderful. So then I had to take a quick Uber over there.
我到了那里，队伍排到了门外，绕过了拐角，所以我排进队里，开始在YouTube上看主题演讲，因为我们确实在YouTube上直播主题演讲。我排到四分之一的时候，有个人出来说，好了，各位，没位置了。已经完全满了。你们应该去会议中心的观看派对。
And I get there and the line is like out the door and around the corner and so I get in the line and the line and I start watching the keynote on YouTube because we do we do live stream the keynote on YouTube and I make it like a fourth of the way through the line and then some guy comes out and says, all right, that's it, folks. It's completely packed capacity. You should go to the viewing party in the convention center.
在那一刻，我想，你知道吗？也许今天不适合我。但我会告诉你我第一次参加GTC的故事，那是在我来英伟达工作之前，当时我正被Olivier Gros诱惑加入绿色阵营。他让我相信2017年的GTC是值得参加的。我这周一直在讲这个故事的一部分，过去，
And at that point, I was like, you know what? Maybe it's not my day. But I will tell you the story of the first GTC that I went to, which was before I came to work at Nvidia when I was being seduced by Olivier Gros to come over to the green side. And he convinced me that GTC 2017 was a GTC to come to. And I've been telling part of this story all week that it used to be back in the day
当硬件制造商宣布一款新芯片时，比如他们宣布芯片名称的那一天。2017年Jensen宣布Volta的那天，他手里拿着芯片展示给大家看。那真的很令人兴奋。在会议之前你根本不知道会有这个东西。而现在，我们会在会上展示路线图，在芯片发布前一年就宣布下一款芯片，然后我们还会说……
that when a hardware manufacturer, the day that they announced a new chip, the day that we said, hey, here's this chip with this name. The day in 2017 when Jensen announced Volta, he had the chip available to hold it up. And like, you know, that was exciting. It was like you didn't know about this thing before the conference. And like now it's like, you know, we show our roadmap there and it's like we show the
关于下下款芯片的一些信息，甚至还会说出下下下款芯片的名字，也就是Feynman。我也听到了，我很惊讶，我不确定这是不是我第一次听到他说“下下款”，但他几乎是随口一提，就像是，哦，这是Ruben，下一款将以Feynman命名。我当时想，等等，我们现在公开这些东西了吗？是的，部分原因是它会泄露，部分原因是如果你要购买或构建一个10万节点的集群，你需要比以前更早地进行规划。
road we announce the next chip like a year before it's gonna be out and then we say something about the next next chip and then we even like say what the name of the next next next Chip is gonna be which is fine. I heard that as well and I was surprised like I'm not sure that was the first time I've ever heard him say like next next but I well he kind of said it as like a throwaway comment almost it was like oh here's Ruben and also the next one will be named after uh Feynman and I was like wait we make that stuff public now yeah well I mean part of it is because it's going to leak part of it is because if you're buying if you're building a 100 000 cluster, you need to do your planning a little bit further in advance than you used to.
对于消费类产品，我们仍然不会提前三年宣布，因为对于消费类产品，你仍然需要那种魔力。但我感觉我们失去了一点魔力，因为我认为CEO走上舞台，你不知道会不会有新芯片，这本身就很神奇。然后他说，哦，这是新芯片。然后他展示出来，举起来。那真的很神奇，2017年的GTC，当他发布Volta时，我感到非常难过，
And like for consumer products, for consumer products, we still don't announce things three years ahead of time because like with consumer products, you can still have the magic. But I feel like we've lost a little bit of the magic because I think there was something magical about the CEO going up on stage and you're not knowing if there's going to be a new chip or not. And then he says, oh, here's the new chip. And then he does the showman thing and then he holds it up. And it was really magical, GTC 2017, when he launched Volta, which was I'm incredibly sad,
因为Volta现在已经接近生命周期的终点。它现在是一个8岁的GPU了。对我来说，它永远是“新”GPU，因为它是一个变革性的架构。我相信它是第一个拥有Tensor Core的架构。它也是第一个我们可以完全且正确地支持C++的架构，因为它是第一个在GPU上拥有独立线程的架构，每个线程都有自己的独立程序计数器。所以你可以在线程之间编写正确的同步代码。
because Volta is now approaching the end of its life. It's an eight-year-old GPU now. And to me, it will always be the new GPU, because it was a transformative architecture. It was the, I believe, the first architecture where we had tensor cores. It was also the first architecture where we could fully and properly support C++ because it was the first architecture where we had independent threading on the GPUs, where each thread had its own independent program counter. And so you could write proper synchronizing code between the GPUs where each thread had its own independent program counter. And so you could write proper synchronizing code between threads.
Volta在可编程性和性能方面比之前的GPU有了巨大的飞跃。我们几乎把世界分成了Volta之前和Volta之后，现在它接近生命周期的终点，这让我很难过。那是带我进入英伟达的GPU，我参加了2017年的主题演讲。我当时住在伯克利。我早上5点起床，开车下去。
And there was a bunch of other ways in which Volta was just a huge leap in terms of programmability and performance over the previous GPUs. And really we almost divided the world into pre-vault and post-vault and now it's like it's approaching the end of its lifetime and it makes me sad. That was the GPU that brought me to NVIDIA that I went to the keynote in 2017. I was living in Berkeley at the time. I woke up at like 5 a.m. I drove down.
我在会议中心找到了停车位。这是在主题演讲还在会议中心举办的时候，在英伟达变得这么大之前。我到了主题演讲现场，我到得很早，我是第一批进入房间的人，前面有一个区域标着“仅限媒体”。Connor，你知道我决定坐在哪里吗？我要冒个险说，你坐在了那个区域，Bryce，媒体区。我当时在Twitter上直播了主题演讲，所以可以说我属于媒体区，因为我在直播主题演讲的照片。
I found parking at the convention center. This was back when the keynote was at the time I woke up at like 5 a.m. I drove down I found parking at the convention center this was back when the keynote was at the convention center before in video was big thing and I got to the keynote and I was there really early I got into the room I was in the first people in the room and there was a section up front that was labeled press only. Connor do you know where I decided to sit? I'm gonna go out on a I'm gonna go out on a real thin limb here and say that you sat in that section Bryce Press only section and I live tweeted the The keynote so I guess arguably I belonged in the press section because I was live tweeting pictures the keynote
我试着找到那条Twitter线程来转发，你知道，想说“嘿，这是我上次参加GTC的时候”。但我认为通过直播2017年GTC主题演讲，我积累了不少粉丝。那是一场神奇的GTC。然后我去看Olivier的演讲《Inside Volta》，他和我们前同事Luke Durant谈论了所有的架构细节，那真是一件神奇的事情。但现在，天哪，现在的会议以非常不同的方式变得神奇，因为它是一个巨大的活动，每个人都在这里，每个人都想了解CUDA和英伟达GPU，如果你戴着英伟达的胸牌走来走去，你就是摇滚明星，这真的很不一样。确实如此。是的，今年我们推出了全新的课程，教大家如何为我们的平台编写现代C++程序。因为我们的平台已经存在20年了，所以问题在于很多现有的教学材料
I tried to find the Twitter thread To retweet, you know to be like hey, this is the last time I was at GTC. But I think that built up quite a critter following from live tweeting the 2017 GTC keynote. And it was a magical GTC. And then I went to watch Olivier's talk called Inside Volta, where he and him and our former colleague Luke Durant talked about all the architectural
都是旧的，教人们以非地道的方式为我们的平台编写C++代码。很多教学材料在10年前可能很棒，但现在已经过时了。所以我们完全改变了教授GPU编程的方法。这也是我演讲涵盖的一部分。我们发布了所有这些课程材料，教授这种新方法。我们现在也非常重视Python，所以我们正在尝试弄清楚如何以同样的方式教授C++、Python和其他语言的API。我们也开始关注其他语言了。好吧，太完美了，你提到了你的演讲。这是一个完美的过渡。所以现在，如果……我们也开始关注其他语言了。好吧，太完美了，你提到了你的演讲。这是一个完美的过渡。
details and it was just a magical thing. But now, oh man, now the conference is magical in very different ways because it's this giant event and everyone's here, everyone wants to learn about CUDA and about Nvidia GPUs and if you walk around with an Nvidia badge there and you're a rock star and it's really something else. It really is. Yeah and we this year we've been we've launched this whole new curriculum for how we teach modern C++ programming for our platform. Because our platform's been around for 20 years, and so the problem is that a lot of the teaching material
所以现在，如果你愿意，听众朋友，请随意暂停这个播客。你可能不会。如果我是你，处在你的位置，没看过Bryce的演讲，我个人不会暂停。也许你已经看过了。但如果你愿意，如果你有兴趣，
that's out there is older teaching material, and it's teaching people how to write C++ code for our platform in a non-idiomatic way. And like a lot of the teaching material was maybe great, you know, 10 years ago, but it's just become outdated. And so we've completely changed our approach for how we teach GPU programming. And that's part of what my talk covered. We've put out all
你可以暂停一下，去看看Bryce的演讲。链接会在节目说明中，然后你可以回来。演讲中提到了几个问题。如果你确实暂停了。现在我要问我的问题了。首先，这不是一个问题，而是一个评论。我总是忘记，但每当我观看你的演讲时，Bryce，我都会想起我们对精美幻灯片的共同热情。你制作了一些……我的意思是，我通常会在某种程度上写一份所谓的“旅行报告”，
this course material that teaches this new way. We're also now like very big on Python and so we're sort of trying to figure out how can we teach C++, how can we teach our APIs in the same way in C++ and Python and in other languages. We're starting to care about other languages too. Alright perfect you brought up your talk. This is a perfect transition. So now if and in other languages. We're starting to care about other languages too. All right, perfect. You brought up your talk. This is a perfect transition.
自从我在英伟达工作以来，只要有GTC，我都会写，因为显然COVID那年取消了。去年，我想因为是疫情后首次线下举办，他们有一些录制问题，所以我的旅行报告有点乱，因为我一直在等J-Cams的演讲发布来完成它，但最终没有录像。总之，我喜欢做的一件事是截取亮点，如果我看了JAX或XLA的演讲，他们有很棒的幻灯片，我会截图。我想我截了八九张你的幻灯片。我想比较一下，我还没看完《What's CUDA all about anyway》那个演讲，但有两张不同的幻灯片。一张来自……我不认识他，但他姓Armstrong。我想是Rob Armstrong，他在做那个演讲。Rob Armstrong，是的。他有一张GPU对比CPU的幻灯片，你也有。
So now, if you would like listener, feel free to pause this podcast. You're probably not going to. I wouldn't personally, if I were you and I was in your shoes right now, not having watched Bryce's talk. Maybe you have already. But if you want, if you are so inclined,
我不是要贬低Rob的幻灯片，但你的，天哪，更漂亮。你还有那张带有渐变的主机/设备图，太美了。我看到时心想，这就是Bryce的巅峰之作。总之，你刚才说你花了最后两周时间准备幻灯片。
you can pause this, go watch Bryce's talk. Link will be in the show notes and then you can come back. There was just a couple of questions asked in the talk. If you did go and pause it. And now I shall ask my questions. First of all, it is not a question, but a comment I always, I always forget. And I'm always reminded when I watch one of your talks, Bryce of the shared passion that we have for beautiful slides. You make some of the, I mean, I usually to some extent write a quote unquote trip report
这绝对看得出来。是的，有趣的是，几年前我决定要更频繁地演讲，但更规律地讲同一个演讲。我过去常做一个演讲，只讲一两次。我决定的是，我不想一年做三四个演讲，我想做一个非常非常好的演讲，然后一年讲十次或二十次。这种哲学的一部分是，我想把这个演讲讲到烂熟于心。所以我做的演讲少了，但我投入的精力多了，因为我做这个演讲时，我知道我压力这么大、这么努力的原因是，我马上就要……
for every GTC ever since I've been at Nvidia when there was a GTC because obviously COVID year they canceled it, the first one. Last year, I think they, because it was the first one back in person they had some recording issues and so my trip report kind of fell apart because I was waiting for j cams ads talk to be released to like complete it but then it never ended up having a recording. Anyways one of my things I like to do is I like to take screenshots of like the highlights you know if I watch a jacks or xla talk and they've got some nice you know slide I take a slide I think I took. Eight or nine screenshots of your deck. What are some of the, I mean, I'm gonna compare, I haven't finished the what's CUDA all about anyway talk, but there's two different slides. One from, I don't actually know him, but his last name's Armstrong. I think Rob Armstrong, he's giving that talk. Rob Armstrong, yeah. He has a GPU versus CPU slide, you have a GPU versus CPU slide.
我做了这个演讲，今天是几号？20号。我18号做了演讲。3月27日，我要在巴黎做这个演讲。3月31日，我要在伦敦做这个演讲。在接下来的八到十个月里，我每个月要讲两三次。另一个重大决定是为我所有的演讲写脚本。
I don't need to, I don't mean to dunk on Rob's slide, but yours, much, Jeff's kiss, much more beautiful. You also have that host slash device with the gradient from beautiful, beautiful. I saw that and I was like, this is Bryce at his finest. Anyways, so just, you said you spent the last two weeks on your slides.
我有我要说的话的脚本。这总是让我感到惊讶，每个演讲都有一个时间目标。我总是先完成所有内容，然后很少在演讲前测试需要多长时间。因为我通常做60分钟的演讲，我只是制作内容，它刚好能塞进60分钟，不需要任何思考。有时我可以扫一眼，觉得这可能太多了，或者太少了。这次，我需要在35分钟内完成演讲，我有点担心，因为这不是我通常的时间目标。所以我做了一次预演，跑了一遍脚本，结果是36分24秒。太完美了。它不知怎么地刚好达到了完美长度。但我喜欢为演讲写脚本，因为我觉得在讲过两三次之后，我可以不用听起来太像在念稿。它仍然会听起来有点像脚本，但我可以做到不那么生硬，而且不用担心跑题。一旦我掌握了时间，我就不用担心需要多长时间。我可以让它更一致，为听众提供更好的体验。我喜欢讲10次或20次的原因之一是，到第10次时，我已经记住了大部分脚本。所以现在我很稳定。听起来很自然，而且很一致。好吧，值得深思。我的意思是，我不写脚本，但这个演讲的结果非常好。就像我说的，我查了一下，我想我说的是七八张，我截了五张图。所以不是八九张，但绝对是我看过的所有演讲中截图最多的一次，这让我……
It definitely shows. Yeah. It's interesting now that a couple of years ago, I made the decision that I was going to speak a lot more frequently, but give the same talk more regularly. I used to make a talk, and I would give a talk once or twice. And what I decided was, I don't want to make three or and I would give a talk once or twice and what I decided was I don't want to make
我不会共享屏幕，因为没必要，你会知道我说的是哪些幻灯片，也许我们会把它包含在节目说明中。这是我最喜欢的幻灯片。请务必在你的播客应用或adsp-the-podcast.com查看节目说明，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Three or four or five talks a year I want to make one really really good talk and I want to give it ten or twenty times a year and part of The philosophy is I want to give the talk so many times that it becomes Just like like that. I mastered the. And so I think I make fewer talks, but I put so much more effort into the talk because like I made this talk knowing the reason I was so stressed and pushing so hard for it is I'm gonna like, I'm immediately turning around.
每年三四五场演讲，我只想精心准备一场真正高质量的演讲，然后一年讲个十到二十次。我的理念是，通过反复演讲，让它变得炉火纯青。所以我做的演讲场次更少，但投入的精力更多。我之所以如此紧张、如此拼命地准备这场演讲，是因为我知道我马上就要开始巡回演讲了。
I gave this talk, what's today? It's the 20th. I gave the talk on the 18th. On March 27th, I'm gonna be giving the talk in Paris. On March 31st, I'm to be giving the talk in London. And I'm going to be giving the talk like two or three times a month for the next, you know, eight or ten months. And then the other big decision I made is to script all my talks.
今天是20号，我18号刚讲完这场演讲。3月27日，我要去巴黎讲；3月31日，我要去伦敦讲。在接下来的八到十个月里，我大概每个月会讲两到三次。我做的另一个重大决定是，我所有的演讲都会写逐字稿。
I have a script of what I'm going to say. And it always amazes me where, like, you know, every talk there's a time target of like how long I'm supposed to make the talk for. And what I always do is I go through and I make all the content and then if I have, it's like I very rarely test how long it takes before I give the talk. Because I usually give 60 minute talks and I usually just make the content and it happens to fit in 60 minutes just without any thought about it. And sometimes I can just look through and I can just eyeball it, like maybe this is
我会把要说的内容写成逐字稿。让我惊讶的是，每次演讲都有预定的时长目标。我通常的做法是先准备好所有内容，很少在演讲前测试时长。因为我通常做的是60分钟的演讲，准备内容时往往不需要刻意计算，时长就刚好合适。有时我扫一眼就能大概判断出内容是多了还是少了。
too much, maybe this is too little. In this case, I needed to give the talk in 35 minutes and I was a little worried about that because it's not my usual time target. And so I did one dry run through where I went through and ran through my script and it ended with like 36 minutes and 24 seconds. And it was just like, it was perfect. It was just, it somehow kicked the perfect length. But I love, I love scripting the talks because I feel like for the most part after I've given the talk two
这次我需要在35分钟内讲完，这和平时的时长目标不同，所以我有点担心。于是我进行了一次预演，把逐字稿过了一遍，结果用了36分24秒。简直太完美了，时长刚好合适。我喜欢写逐字稿，因为我觉得在讲过两三次之后，我的表达就不会显得太生硬。
or three times I can do the delivery without it sounding too scripted. It'll still sound a little scripted but I can do the delivery without it sounding too scripted and then I don't have to worry about going off on tangents. I don't have to once I've got the timing, I don't have to worry about how long it's gonna take. I can make it more consistent and a better experience for the people I'm giving the talk to. And one of the reasons why I love giving the talk 10 or 20 times is by the time I've gotten to,
虽然听起来还是会有一点点像照本宣科，但不会太明显，而且我不用担心跑题。一旦确定了时间，我就不用担心超时问题。这样我可以让演讲更连贯，给听众带来更好的体验。我喜欢讲十到二十次的原因是，讲到第十次的时候，我已经记住了大部分内容。
you know, the 10th time I've given the talk, I've memorized most of the script. And so now I'm just, I'm just consistent. It just sounds natural and it's just consistent All right food for thought. I mean I do not script my talks But the result of this talk it's it's very good. And like I said these and I actually I went and checked I think I said it was seven or eight. I took one two three four five screenshots five screenshots So not not eight or nine, but definitely the most I've taken of any other talk I've watched is one which leads me to I mean, I'm not gonna share screen share because we don't need to you'll know the slides
所以现在我讲起来非常连贯，听起来很自然，而且始终如一。好吧，这很值得深思。虽然我不写逐字稿，但这场演讲的效果确实非常好。正如我所说，我特意去查了一下，我截了五张图，而不是七八张。我平时看其他演讲最多也就截一张图，这说明这场演讲的内容非常值得记录。我就不共享屏幕了，因为你们肯定知道我说的是哪几张幻灯片。
I'm talking about and maybe we'll include it in the show notes By far my favorite slide Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ad sp the podcast com for links to anything We mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening, we hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也许我们会把这些幻灯片放在节目笔记里。这是我最喜欢的一张幻灯片。请务必查看播客应用中的节目笔记，或访问adsp the podcast com获取今天节目中提到的所有链接，以及GitHub讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。